you know we love to end off on some good  vibes and this time with one america's  got talent act unlike anything we've  seen before yeah in a preview for  tonight's episode an artificial  intelligence group shocks the judges  after bringing simon cowell's singing  voice to life by using deep fake  technology yes you heard that right  metaphysic is joined by former agt star  daniel emmett who is actually doing the  singing when simon is seen on screen  performing you're the inspiration by  chicago take a look and we will see you  next time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you know what love was meant to be  [Applause]  and i want you here with me  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  i wanna have you hear me  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  is